unter der woche mussten sowohl
hoffenheim als auch dortmund das
pokal-aus verdauen die bessere reaktion
auf das ausscheiden zeigt zunächst
dortmund in dem erling hollern einen
starken bvb spielzug in minute sechs zum
100 veredelt in der folge die gäste
offensiv aber zu passiv der ausgleich
durch andere kramer rich in der
nachspielzeit der ersten hälfte völlig
verdient
dortmund tut sich insgesamt schwer kann
aber kurz nach einer systemumstellung
auf dreierkette durch marco reus die
führung in minute 58 wieder herstellen
neun minuten später geht es wieder über
den starken toni l malen dessen
hereingabe den raum vorsah klären
schießt den ball damit aber ins eigene
tor 3 zu 1 bvb die kraichgauer aber
mitnichten gebrochen kommen durch junior
und der 77 minute nochmal zum
anschlusstreffer zu mehr reicht es
allerdings nicht dortmund gewinnt und
setzt damit die bayern mal wieder unter
druck
[Applaus]
um den bvb weiter auf abstand zu halten
brauchen die münchner also drei punkte
gegen die hertha und so ist es kein
wunder dass die gäste von beginn an das
kommando übernehmen und sich dafür auch
belohnen für toni so die führung nach 25
minuten der fcb absolut dominant drückt
aus zwei zu null sané täuscht den
freistoß an chemisch hört aus und thomas
müller vollstreckt in minute 45 der
treffer hoch verdient die härter zu
beginn des zweiten durchgangs besser
drin treffen tun aber wieder die bayern
dank dieses patzers von schwolow sané
mit dem 30 minute 75 und
noch haben die münchner nicht genug 79
minute geschickt nabu und der lässt sich
das allein vorsprung nicht mehr nehmen
vier zu null nur eine minute später
leistet sich dann über americano den
fehler jovetic kann die noch nicht
nutzen aber allen kam vier zu eins
dieses tor aber reinste ergebniskosmetik
denn dabei bleibt es die bayern gewinnen
und marschieren unbeirrt weiter vorneweg
ihre champions league ambitionen
unterstreichen wollen die leverkusener
gegen augsburg und das gelingt von
beginn an am ball arabi in der zwölften
spielminute aus spitzen winkel zum 1 0
schon der zwölfte bayer-treffer dieser
saison in der anfangsviertelstunde auch
danach leverkusen die dominantere
mannschaft wofür sie sich in minute 22
in person von user diaby belohnen zwei
zu null im zweiten durchgang augsburg
etwas offensiver was immerhin zum
anschlusstreffer in minute 62 führt das
2 1 von arne meyer gleichzeitig sein
erster bundesligatreffer
die hoffnung währte aber nur kurz denn
nur drei minuten später stellt news.at
abi den alten vorsprung wieder her
wieder nur vier minuten später ist
erneut der franzose zur stelle erzählt
mit seinem dritten treffer das 4 zu 1
den schön anzuschauenden schlusspunkt
dieser partie setzt an die kassa lario
mit dem 51 in der 81 minute per hacke
ambitionen also eindrucksvoll
unterstrichen
europa ambitionen haben neuerdings auch
die kölner die gegen bochum zu beginn
aber erst mal einen kleinen dämpfer
erhalten bei holtmann in minute 25 auf 1
0 für den vfl stellt zu diesem zeitpunkt
auch verdient doch eine slapstick ecke
von kainz immer 36 minute landete über
umwege bei hübers der nicht lange
fackelt und den ball unter die latte
wuchtete eins zu eins nach einem auf
baufehler der bochumer kurz vor der
pause bleibt dann anthony modeste hebt
den ball über keeper riemann zum etwas
überraschenden zwei zu eins für die
kölner in der folge der fc aber zu
passiv und das bestrafen die bochumer
folter in der 70 spielminute mit etwas
glück für asamoah 2 zu 2 am ende eine
gerechte punkteteilung
der tabellenletzte ausführt ist seit
drei spielen zwar ungeschlagen aber ohne
sieg den soll es nun gegen mainz geben
und die kleeblätter tun viel dafür
jeremy dudziak wird von the green in
szene gesetzt 10 in der zwölften
spielminute wird mit der führung im
rücken fortan mit selbstvertrauen in der
66 minute findet ihn wieder du sagst
sein querpass drückte dann ins eigene
tor 20 danach plätscherte das spiel so
vor sich hin bis zur nachspielzeit ohne
sie wo mit dem anschlusstreffer es
bleibt aber beim 2 2 1 führt nun seit
vier spielen ungeschlagen und endlich
auch mal mit drei punkten
einen sieg hätten auch die gladbacher
nach zwei niederlagen in folge dringend
mal wieder nötig ein vorhaben das schon
nach 18 minuten ein sehr schweres zu
werden scheint max kruse per
handelfmeter zum 1 0 für die gäste aus
berlin
es dauert eine weile bis sich die fohlen
von dem schock erholen aber es gelingt
ihnen kollegin der vierzigsten mit
seinem ersten bundesliga treffer zum
verdienten ausgleich auch im zweiten
durchgang die hausherren das bessere
team der treffer will aber nicht feind
der gelingt dafür ausgerechnet dem ex
gladbacher max kruse zum zweiten mal in
dieser partie 21 union und gladbach
damit weiter im freien fall
[Applaus]
mit einem 4 2 1 pokalerfolg gegen
hoffenheim im rücken will freiburg nun
auf den ersten bundesliga sieg im neuen
jahr gegner stuttgart zu beginn gut
dagegen gerät dann aber unglücklich in
rückstand weil ito den distanzschuss vom
häfler in der 37 minute ins eigene tor
abfälschte zur pause dann ein kurioser
wechsel weil schiedsrichter stieler
nicht weitermachen kann für ihn
übernimmt der vierte offizielle dingert
und der sieht im zweiten durchgang
starke freiburger logische konsequenz
ist das 2 0 durch schadet in der 1
in studien heute übrigens dass vier
hundertstel freiburger bundesliga tor
unter christian streicht das 2 0 dann
auch der endstand freiburg auch in der
liga wieder in der spur
zurück in die spur finden will auch
endlich wieder wolfsburg gegen leipzig
seit zehn pflichtspielen warten die
wölfe auf einen sieg und nach 76 minuten
beklagt sie werden wohl noch länger
warten müssen zunächst fünf zimmer zwar
die werte aber dann kam entscheidend
nachsetzen und drückt den ball zum 1 0
über die linie nur acht minuten später
kam rb dem sack dann zumachen mobile hat
das auge für cardiol der treffer
zunächst aufgrund einer abseitsposition
nicht gegeben der video assistent greift
aber zu recht ein radio nicht in der
verbotenen zone treffer zählt leipzig
gewinnt 2 zu 0 und wolfsburg wartet
weiter
[Applaus]
in frankfurt wollen sich formstarke
bielefelder weiter aus der abstiegszone
schießen entsprechend liegt die arminia
auch los keine fünf minuten dauert es da
darf wimmer jubeln wenn auch mit
freundlicher unterstützung von chandler
die eintracht auf der suche nach einer
antwort aber ohne zündende idee die
beste idee des spiels hat dann der
richtig gut aufgelegte wimmer in der 28
minute seine ramona flanke wird von
chips brust zum 2 0-endstand veredelt
bielefeld mit starken 11 punkten aus den
letzten fünf spielen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die ergebnisse noch einmal im überblick
leverkusen beeindruckt mit einem 5 2 1
gegen augsburg wird bestätigt seinen
aufwärtstrend mit dem 2 1 gegen mainz
die bayern lassen der hertha beim 4 1
keine chance in der tabelle tut sich
vorne weiter wenig bayern und dortmund
bleiben im titelduell unter sich auf
platz 3 etabliert sich leverkusen und
führt das verfolgerfeld an in der
zweiten tabellenhälfte verlässt
bielefeld die abstiegsränge führt bleibt
tabellenletzter rückt aber etwas näher
ran an stuttgart auf 17
[Musik]